Mom I'm very grateful for you I love you
never forget that what do you get the
woman who has everything for Mother's
Day sweet video tributes and that's
exactly what Kim Kardashian's kiddos did
on Sunday I don't know what's gonna top
that the reality star celebrated Mama's
Day with her famous family over brunch
she's so cute
our little Mother's Day brunch
mom and my grandma
and our kids
and Kim revealed to her sister Chloe
gave her the sweetest gift of all she
made these for all of us
love you
you are the best in the world you make
my day every day
[Applause]
yep that's nine-year-old North
seven-year-old Saint five-year-old
Chicago and four-year-old song whom Kim
shares with her ex Kanye West I want to
make sure each kid gets so much of my
attention I think four is the perfect
magic number for me and if you wanted to
hear more you're in luck cue the
Waterworks courtesy saint
Mom I'm very grateful for you I know I'm
rude to you a lot I say you're nothing
to me but you mean the world to me I
love you more than anything
you're my favorite in the family I even
love you more than my little cute little
brother song
I love you never forget that I do feel
like my house is so full but in the best
way ad while Saint was giving Mom all
the feels I'm very happy little shy
brought the LOLs it's really fun to see
Kim shared this worksheet and shy filled
in the blanks her most noteworthy
answers Chicago says her mom is 22 years
old which Kim who is 42 said made her
feel seen I'm really honored and humbled
she says her mom is really good at going
to the gym I've just started to try and
eat really healthy and you know work out
a little bit more just change my
lifestyle her favorite food is salad and
when asked about the best meal her mom
cooks Shy's response mom doesn't cook
she has a chef yeah Kim posted a crying
laughing emoji alongside that answer and
at the family brunch she jokingly shut
down Shai's kitchen clean sharing this
pick from the stove insisting shy was
wrong I do cook lol having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot clearly Kim loves being a mom with a
source recently telling E.T that she's
living her best life and isn't taking
herself too seriously you just gotta
roll with it she has amazing energy
right now and everyone around her loves
it and that energy will be on full
display when the famous family's Hulu
series returns May 25th I'm really
confused how this narrative came into
her head like I couldn't have been more
mindful people think that's a
misunderstanding it's not it's who she
is to her core here's hoping we'll see
plenty of drama but also Sweet Moments
Like This
I love you never forget that
[Music]